make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so those people who are familiar
with Carol Danvers knew that we had to
do this story this actually happens in
Avengers annual number ten but not
really so
to the casual comic book reader people
say like Avengers annual number ten is
the first appearance of road and that's
where rogue steals of powers of Carroll
of Carrollton burst but that's not
entirely true so kind of wind the clock
back a little bit to like the late 1970s
and the early 1980s and then jump
forward to 1992
so when Miss Marvel had her original
solo series in the form of Miss Marvel
Chris Claremont had this idea to roll
her into the x-men the problem was that
Marvel editorial at the time and the way
that Chris Claremont wrote his stories
wouldn't really allow for like a sudden
shift and so in the old Miss Marvel
stories he winded up having mystique who
made her appearance she reformed the
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants and then for
a reason that was never fully explained
mystique had a vendetta against Miss
Marvel but the reason why was never
explained was because the comic was
cancelled before we could actually see
what happened and so that fast forwards
tonight to 92 with Marvel superheroes
volume 2 issue number 11 and what this
did is it brought in this this really
like first fight between rogue and Miss
Marvel and what Avengers annual number
10 is actually pick up directly after
that fight but the way this played out
is that you had mystique and then you
had somebody named destiny now for those
of you guys who are who are not familiar
with Marvel Comics destiny is an old
name and she hasn't been around for a
long long time she was killed off
decades ago but destiny was the lover of
mystique and she was a pre Capri
cognitive psychic who could see the
future and it was a way for Claremont to
basically like introduce things right so
you had like the diaries of Destiny
different things like that but she was
also super useful in the sense that like
she could be in a fight which will
actually see an Avengers annual number
ten she could be in a fight and show
guide people on what to do based on
what's going to happen but but
nonetheless it's one of those
interesting scenarios and so what ended
up happening here is that in the
original story is really in the
unpublished story as it was released to
Marvel superheroes 11th Destiny had
revealed to mystique that Miss Marvel
was going to kill her Miss Marvel and
Robo get into a fight and rogue would
died and because rogue was was believed
to be the daughter of mystique and the
very least like an adopted daughter
this led mystique into fighting Miss
Marvel by basically bringing together
the brought the second iteration of the
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants so like
avalanche blobbin and pyro and so they
were basically a symbol by mystique they
fought against Miss Marvel and Miss
Marvel won and so what ended up
happening here is that following that
and with world
realizing what was happening she
interned ran off and fought Miss Marvel
and so when this skirmish had took place
between the two of them in San Francisco
that led to the Golden Gate Bridge that
rogue basically grabbed Miss Marvel and
then held on for too long and when that
happened was she stole her powers but
then also stole her memories and then it
was a permanent transition and so what
that was designed to do because it was
kind of this untold story is technically
it comes before the events of Avengers
annual number ten but it really just
kind of explains what goes on in this
particular comic and so when this picks
up you basically have Carol Danvers
who's thrown off the bridge by rogue
after rogue absorbs all of her memories
powers and so on and then in turn like
she's rescued by Jessica drew now with
this going forward Jessica drew
immediately takes her to a local police
station and this one time Jessica drew
is basically operating out of San
Francisco proper and really she's based
in LA but it was a way for Marvel to
kind of have like another spider
character that wasn't really going to
conflict with what Peter Parker was
doing in New York kind of give her her
own identity her own base of operations
her own city to protect and so on and so
forth but one of the things to bear in
mind is that by and large this era in
Marvel Comics still somewhat maintained
the kind of separation between the
Avengers Fantastic Four in the x-men and
so one of the things you guys are gonna
see is that the x-men are not fully
aware of the things that go on with the
Avengers and the Avengers are not fully
aware of what goes on with the EX minute
so it's one of these these cool little
scenarios because this whole kind of
catching up is done in this Avengers
annual in this sense it like were
explained who it is that that Carol
Danvers is that she was an Air Force
pilot she basically took the Kree
physiology of the original Marvel she
got like you know all of his powers and
abilities and they went forward as a
superhero and and so on and so forth
like that's kind of how those things
unfolded and so with this scenario
playing out the way that it is the
detective on the scene the original cop
that shows up doesn't really know
exactly what to make of all this the
doctor doesn't really know what to make
of all this
this is a little wild here no one really
knows how to handle the situation but
Jessica drew does she basically reaches
out and says Charles Xavier can
basically penetrate her mind can read
her mind and figure out what's happening
here so this leads into the arrival of
the x-men now what is up happening is he
basically reads the mind of Carroll and
says what's going on at least you know
telepathically communicates with Jessica
and says what's going on here is that
her mind has basically been wiped now
one of the things that Claremont did
here that he didn't do all the time was
basically give us like the full-on
explanation of what rogues about within
the confines of this issue and I
remember the reason why this was done
this way is because it was a special
situation that Claremont's plot threads
on the Miss marvel
Tomic weren't allowed to be developed
and so we really just kind of had to
like include plot threads in here you
know in this this particular story here
and there and then just kind of run with
it but the idea is that under normal
circumstances Claremont would usually
draw things out but of course with rogue
herself that's the image that's given a
Jessica drew and so at the moment right
now Jessica drew at Charles Xavier and
Carol Danvers are the only ones who
really know what happened to Carol
everybody else is just kind of flying
blind and this happens when when rogue
basically shows up out of injures
mansion and wrecks Captain America now
that's the important thing to bear in
mind and this is what Claremont really
kind of flushes things out fast within
the span of two panels what he basically
establishes here is that in her early
appearances rogue could absorb any
number of powers there was no limit to
the number of powers she could absorb
and she could hold them all at the same
time but as she held on for too long she
could potentially kill a person and the
powers she absorbed be permanent meaning
under normal circumstances they're
temporary and so that's that's why it
was it was kind of a cool thing isn't
because it basically fleshed out her
character in a very short amount of time
but she also absorbs knowledge and
memories and that's what makes her so
formidable here is because by absorbing
the knowledge and memories of Captain
America while she does get all the World
War two stuff she doesn't really need
what she does get is that with Captain
America kind of be in the leader of the
Avengers team essentially she knows all
the Avengers strengths and weaknesses
she knows her fighting formations she
knows how they're most likely to respond
she knows the identities of everybody
the Captain America knows she's
literally like a Swiss Army knife a
one-woman wrecking machine that's going
to go in here and just wreck all the
Avengers and that's exactly what happens
is because when you have basically
Captain America who's thrown through the
window of Avengers mansion and all the
other members begin to panic and like we
have to respond Tony Stark down in his
lab is met by the arrival of Janet Van
Dyne Lister this is kind of cool here
this is all the reasons why I love
Claremont storytelling is because things
always came out of left field is because
when with with Janet Van Dyne she's a
well-established member of the Avengers
she's one of the people who founded the
team and so there's no reason for Tony
Stark to question the allegiance or the
alliances of Janet Van Daan but this is
not Janet this is a mystique and so when
mystique gets in here she literally
attaches a device to the back of Ironman
suit and it mobilizes him and shuts him
down that's the great thing about
Claremont storytelling it's just the
small things the phone call that goes on
between you know between Iron Man and
Thor
well it seems uh nacelle what it does is
it builds cohesiveness he hits him up
and he says hey look man you know before
mystique attached to me hit him up says
Captain America has been mugged I know
it sounds crazy but somebody mud cap you
got to get out here small little things
like that the small little comm
small discussions that went on behind
the scenes that were essentially anak
ewis things like that that's what really
helped to build the characters and give
them personality now of course this
plays out exactly the way you would
expect it to in the sense that when Thor
shows up and when Jessica drew shows up
of course Jessica drew everything but
her mouth being covered by her suit
makes it impossible for rogue to
basically take her powers no rogue could
touch her mouth the problem with this is
that for for Spider Woman
she's so agile and she moves so fast
that it's impossible for rogue to catch
her and so it's kind of a cool little
thing here because in response to that
where Thor is seem to have been
temporarily knocked unconscious by rope
when he regains his stick and then he
gets his hammer back that in turn leads
to rogue attacking him now for the non
comic reader I want to explain this for
a second back when Thor first showed up
in Marvel Comics there was a caveat to
him in the early days of Asgard Thor was
very humorous he was full of hubris he
was very he was very cocky and arrogant
owned simpler to earth in order to teach
him humility and so he put him in the
body of a man named Donald Blake and
then wiped his knowledge of Thor and it
said somewhere along the line Donald
Blake will prove himself worthy and when
he does he'll find the hammer of Thor
and then he'll become Thor and that's
what happened he found a walking stick
he got frustrated hit it on the ground
and it turned into Mele near the hammer
fort and Donald Blake became four and so
going forward from that point what did
what would happen is that if Thor lost
the connection to is to his hammer for
sixty seconds he would turn back into
Donal Blake it was a way for him to
basically have a dual identity like
Superman and Clark Kent but with Jessica
drew trying to basically launch an
attack against rogue before rogue can
fully steal the powers of Thor she
doesn't do it in time it's a rogue
basically has all the abilities of
Captain America and the knowledge of
Captain America all the powers of
knowledge of Thor and she's got all the
powers of knowledge of Carol Danvers
she's a powerhouse now following this
rogue encounters a first person that she
meets as you can't really absorb
anything from because they're not
technically human and that Simon
Williams Wonder Man now Simon Williams
was originally a human being like he was
originally a normal guy who could
function do his own thing he appeared
back in Avengers number nine back in
1964 but the basis behind him was that
he was a test it was it was kind of a
test by marvel to see whether or not
people were receptive to it and so what
ended up happening when he was created
by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby he was
created with a ticking clock which is to
say that somewhere along the line he'll
basically died and the idea behind this
was that Baron Zemo had basically
brought in Simon Williams and then
bombarded him with ionized radiation
more or less which would basically give
him like super strength the super speed
and you know
durability and different things like
that he ended up joining the masters of
evil he fought against the Avengers and
then joined the team later on but the
big change that happened to him came in
Avengers number 164 and the reason why
was because after Simon Williams was
believed to have died due to the fact
that his body just kind of burned out
more or less that he essentially like
reconstituted now this was also done by
his brother Eric Williams the Grim
Reaper but that's not super important he
kind of had a hand in it but nonetheless
Simon Williams basically re-emerges but
he reappeared on ik energy and so
there's no flesh and blood inside and
Williams the ionic energy he has is what
gives him his physical form but aside
from that there's no bone there's no
muscle no none of that stuff it's
literally a heat like a skin shell
that's housing like all this high onic
energy and so because of that this is
chris claremont establishing yet another
principal of rogue that she can only
absorb powers from those who aren't
living beings and so it was an
interesting little caveat we end up
having in turn following this mystique
basically taking the armor taking the
taking Tony Stark in his suit putting
him in a satellite and then dropping him
down into a prison and basically freeing
almost everybody this in their freedom
and freedom from Rikers Island now this
is basically where Mystique's
Brotherhood of Evil Mutants is housed so
like pyro and the blob and and Avalanche
and those guys now the reason why
they're here is because this comes
almost immediately in the aftermath of
Days of Future past and so were the the
the brotherhood of mystique had tried to
kill Senator Robert Kelley and Charles
Xavier Mora McTaggart or Kitty Pryde had
come from the future to basically stop
that when the whole plot was thwarted
the forces of mystique - mystique
herself were taken to Rikers Island and
they were dropped off and that's where
they've been ever since and so this is
really all just one giant ploy for
mystique to reassemble her Brotherhood
of Evil Mutants the problem with this is
that she's also got destiny at her side
and with destiny at her side what this
does is it allows her to basically see
what's going to happen and in the
counter all the moves of the Avengers
before they ever make them and so that's
why it's kind of a cool thing is because
you've also got rogue facing off here
along had the Brotherhood and so on and
so forth and they do pretty well but as
soon as destiny is basically kind of
removed from the equation right like as
soon as destiny is is essentially like
defeated here what this does is it leads
into the rest of the Avengers basically
saying look like we can overcome this I
said what mystique ends up doing is
leaving like pyro
leaving blob and leaving Avalanche
behind and then in turn like racing off
like grabbing destiny and racing off and
it was essentially to say like destiny
was the only person that mystique was
really after in the first place which
makes sense because they were
essentially lovers
I mean it you know it all kind of stands
to reason that would be the case but the
battle wraps up quick fast and in a
hurry it's a pretty straightforward
battle the Brotherhood is defeated and
then they're taken prisoner back in
Rikers Island again and that's basically
yet and so what this does is it leads to
the Avengers traveling to the Xavier
Institute and then meeting with Carol
Danvers now Carol Danvers initially
rebukes all of them where she kind of
accepts them to a degree and then
rejects them all when they asked hey how
are you doing is so on and so forth she
freaks out and she ends up leaving and
the reason why is because this kind of
comes off the tail end of Avengers
number 200 and Avengers number 200 was a
weird story this is a story that Chris
Claremont wrote where the idea was that
Carol Danvers basically gave birth to a
guy named Marcus who in turn was a
time-traveling dude named immortus who
kind of gave birth to himself and it's
it's strange it's the craziest thing but
the idea was that in this realm of limbo
where immortus normally resides that
Marcus wanted to I guess the more does
kind of want to give birth to himself or
show up in like the main Marvel Universe
and could you and use Carol Danvers as
it means to do it the problem with this
is that mark is essentially tricked
Carol Danvers that what he did is he
basically like kind of whisked her off
to his realm of limbo and tried to get
her to fall in love with him and
initially she didn't want to but over
time she somewhat did due to what was
what some people call brainwashing and
then in turn using a little bit of
manipulation from the Marcus machines
which are designed to kind of subtly
alter her mind basically got her to fall
in love with him the two of them slept
together and then Marcus himself was
reborn
inside the main Marvel Universe and so
when that happened because Marcus was
reborn in a physical form when they
travel to the realm of limbo
Marcus aged incredibly fast and
basically died within a week and Carol
Danvers of course made her way back but
what what went on here is that Carol
Danvers tried to explain the situation
that from her perspective she was forced
into it but the Avengers didn't really
seem to see it that way or didn't
understand what was being said and the
result was that they celebrated you know
they they congratulated her on her
pregnancy having no real idea what was
going on behind the scenes and so what
this meant was that when the time came
when Carol Danvers basically came back
and had the opportunity to contact the
Avengers she didn't that she was
basically gone for three months in the
realm of limbo she came back and then
vanished for three months and never had
any contact with anybody and looked to
live a quiet life in in San Francisco
and that's when she met rogue for the
first time the two of them fought
leading into the story and so when the
questions asked do you want to rejoin
the Avengers the response of Carol
Danvers is
no and what this did is it basically
brought in what we in the comic book
industry call Ariane the column of
readership
a soft reboot and this is basically
Chris Claremont's way of saying okay so
now that rogue has touched Carol Danvers
rogue has like all the abilities and all
the memories of Carol which is gonna
create a subplot for rug where rogue
Hanna has to fight her own conscience
and like the personality of Carol
Danvers inside rogues own mind but for
Carol herself basically hurt she's still
regaining her memories which that's
gonna take work xavier is the only one
who can really do it we're essentially
gonna kind of like rework her powers and
we're gonna transform her into a
character named binary and she's gonna
be part of the x-men the uncanny x-men
for a little while that was essentially
Chris Claremont goal here following this
annual and going into the future of the
uncanny x-men line Carol Danvers stayed
kind of regained a lot of these memories
that were seemingly taken away by rogue
and then in turn that led into her
interaction with a group called the
brood which basically turned her in a
binary which gave her the powers of a
white dwarf storm what does that mean is
a plot device she can do whatever it is
a crisp clear about wanted her to do
because it's a whole new source of her
power so anyway that's the basis behind
rogue stealing the powers of Carol
Danvers is a cool little sword but if
you guys are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later hoose
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]